[Music]
i was looking in your file
you're not the usual fish are you
i see that sort of behavior
as an advantage for you
it could be advantageous to everyone
including your country
want a gig
tell me why
[Music]
we kidnap people
and transport them to other countries
willing to look the other way while we
interrogate them what do you want do you
know this guy he's radicalizing young
kids you got a 20 on the target
you know what's required get your hands
dirty
no restraints
target's secure
the clock is ticking
somebody is really aching for this guy
there's something they're not telling us
i'm just a foot soldier they don't tell
me anything
the more we know the more we're
accountable to
our mission is to keep the wars small
and sacrifice is meaningful
just because you're american
doesn't mean your colleagues share the
same goal as you
we have a problem
why are you descending
there's been a major shift i'm pulling
the plug
that guy knew we were coming it's
definitely a trap
for all we know this guy's controlling
the whole goddamn thing
we're next we get ready
all i know is control and orders
there's some bigger picture we're not
seeing
no matter how messy this gets
i'm not your enemy
you play a complicated game allegiances
change
we're officially in cleanup mode
it's time for plan b
so what's plan b kill em all
extraction ten seconds
let's do it
[Music]
you